alex taylor journaliste spécialiste des
affaires européennes monsieur taylor
bienvenu merci d'être avec nous en
direct alors boris johnson pas oxygénée
mais placé sous respirateur et en soins
intensifs
vous confirmez donc oui absolument
c'est du moins ce que ce que laissent
sous-entendre autant que les communiqués
mais est ce qu'on peut dire pour le
moment c'est que au niveau comme ça n'a
pas été très clair si jamais très facile
de communiquer sur l'état de santé des
dirigeants
tous les pays ont des problèmes avec ça
mais pour le moment c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'on croit comprendre effectivement
que boris johnson son état de santé
s'est aggravé
lee hier soir il a eu de l'oxygène mais
pour le moment on ferme dernières
nouvelles ils n'étaient pas encore sous
respirateur alors à quel point la
population est inquiète évidemment où la
population est inquiète une situation
plus ou moins inouïe il ya eu des cas où
les dirigeants
je prends des premiers ministres
britanniques ont suivi des opérations
tony blair par exemple là il va souci
détermine opérations étaient prévues les
gens étaient prévenus
winston churchill pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale à une petite crise
cardiaque
ça ne s'est pas su donc comme c'était la
guerre
[Applaudissements]
on peut comprendre que l'information
était étouffée mais là c'est carrément
c'est l'hécatombe
et c'est l'hécatombe aussi parce que le
message n'était pas très clair dès le
départ de la part du gouvernement
britannique et la part de parler johnson
lui même qui à peine il ya un peu plus
de deux semaines je pense que c'est une
conférence de presse lui se vanter de
serrer la main à tout le monde dans un
hôpital où il y avait des malades du
corps vide
19 je pense qu'il voulait rassurer les
gens mais c'était vraiment pas la façon
de le faire est aussi avec des
contradictions dans un propre politique
et sa communication par exemple il
disait que il déconseillé aux
britanniques de se rendre dans les pubs
tout en refusant de les fermer
c'est contradictoire et manque de pot
son propre père est allé à la télévision
le lendemain pour lui dire que lui ils
avaient l'intention de se rendre dans le
pub
si l'on ressentait le besoin donc la
communication était très confuse et on
récolte maintenant malheureusement les
effets justement son état de santé
petit créé une prise de conscience au
niveau de la population
ah oui là c'est clair parce que autant
le message a été confus vous savez aussi
des le break city est pour quelque chose
parce que depuis quatre ans à peu près
boris johnson le premier dit vaguement
au britannique vous vous êtes différent
des européens
c'était un peu l'attitude que c'était un
problème européen et que la grande
bretagne en faisant appel à des
scientifiques avec la politique de
l'immunité de groupe allait s'en sortir
au mieux la combattre a levé de la
chance d'avoir je ne sais pas si on doit
rire du retard de la france par rapport
à des pays comme l'italie il aurait pu
prendre des mesures draconiennes
beaucoup plus tôt ils n'ont pas fait
donc là c'est vraiment cool comment
quitter on en crée le
la larme qui sonne déjà la reine s'est
adressé au peuple
dimanche soir ça devait faire la une le
lendemain mais personne a été
hospitalisée à peine deux heures après
donc ces deux éléments ont vraiment
frappé l'esprit des britanniques et je
pense qu'il y aura beaucoup moins de
gens dans les parcs dans les jours qui
viennent parce que ce week-end il
faisait beau il y avait beaucoup de
britanniques qui se promener dans les
parcs
justement comment ça se passe là bas au
niveau du confinement de la mise au lit
tellement des mesures drastiques ont été
prises
le problème c'est que là encore le
messager et bouyer je vous rappelle que
la grande bretagne c'est un pays où il
n'ya pas de papiers d'identité
vous pouvez circuler personne peut vous
demander de justifier de votre identité
moi je suis à paris je viens de sortir
pour faire mes courses une fois par
semaine il a fallu que je me munissent
d'un document en grand bretagne ce n'est
pas le cas en grand beau temps le
gouvernement dit que si possible de
sortir pendant une heure pour faire du
sport tous les jours mais je dis les
gens dont le parc si les policiers les
arrêtent évidemment très facile de dire
ah bah moi je sors faire du sport et je
suis la seconde depuis cinq minutes ton
qui a aucun contrôle n'est pas de
papiers d'identité et je pense
malheureusement si les chiffres
continuent à grimper
on risque d'avoir des mesures beaucoup
plus strictes surface en grande bretagne
alex taylor merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions